all right uh dozens of you over the
Memorial Day Weekend sending me these
clips of Donald Trump on the golf course
giving a short interview everybody's
saying Trump looks sick David something
is clearly wrong with Trump he's pale
he's low energy his everything about him
just his face is sagging and all these
different things I'm going to look at
the clips let's see what we have he also
is I guess addressing some issues about
Ron DeSantis
if you were on a debate stage with Ron
DeSantis what would you say to him what
would be your interactions with him
because Adam Putnam beat him I don't I
don't know but they say he's not a very
good debater but maybe he is I don't
know we'll find out maybe we'll find out
Because unless he gets close why would
anybody debate all right so Trump there
suggesting he might not even debate
DeSantis unless DeSantis gets close in
polling yeah I mean listen Trump doesn't
look good I think what's going on here
and I'm not trying to be funny or
disrespectful or anything is when Trump
doesn't have
the you know the the dyed hair perfectly
quaffed and perfectly for Trump is an
open to interpretation the spray tan the
suit the entire thing
Trump's an obese older guy and so this
is just what he looks like I think I
think it's that simple I don't know that
Trump is sick necessarily here's another
clip and Trump does seem worse in this
one where he goes after DeSantis for
being disloyal are you angry Mr
President that Ron DeSantis entered the
race
no I think he's a very disloyal person
because he was dead he was looking for
jobs and I endorsed him and he went up
many points he was 30 points down at
least maybe more than that he was dead
so I think he's very disloyal but I
don't care look Paul just came out in
Iowa he saw the one that just came out a
little couple of minutes ago I'm leading
by
30 or 40 points
uh I don't mind that at all but no I
think he's married just a loyal but he's
got no personality if you don't have
personality politics is a very hard
business so Hey listen I actually agree
with this analysis desantis's
personality is just so uh the opposite
of what anybody would ever want to see
at a dinner party or in the in the Oval
Office
um that I I it's obviously it's not just
that he's also a dangerous authoritarian
wannabe I think Trump is actually right
about that Trump doesn't look good he
looks exhausted he looks pale you know
the eyes are almost swollen shut I agree
I think uh it's more of a his energy
seems to be suffering does he have what
it takes
for this campaign particularly if he's
trying to beat off one or one indictment
two indictments potentially three
indictments I think there are some real
questions there but not a great
interview for the failed former
president
when you're using websites and apps your
device sends out data about you into the
open who you are where you go things you
like that data then gets sold around for
advertising purposes which is why every
time I connect to the internet I use a
VPN to hide my IP address and our
sponsor private internet access is the
most trustworthy VPN on the market it's
the only VPN that has proven multiple
times in court they don't log your
activity private internet access
protects you from the prying eyes of
hackers your internet service provider
tech companies private internet access
is also super fast for streaming and for
downloads you can watch your favorite
streaming platforms as if you're in
another country like the UK to access
cool new content and with just one
account you can protect unlimited
devices all at the same time this is
really a game changer private internet
access is giving my audience 83 percent
off that's 203 a month plus four months
free go to Pia vpn.com Pacman the link
is down below